you want to get out your
my one my second challenge was get a
figure that could beat goku okay now
i want you to think open-mindedly here
i'm gonna think very close-minded
[ __ ] you
joey what is that
so this is one of the few russian bun
figures that didn't come in a uh in a
box
it just came by itself
joe you've just bought goku
i know i have not i've bought super
saiyan goku black actually you've bought
black goku
i bought super saiyan goku black because
canonically he does kill goku
yeah but so is half of the [ __ ] cast
in dragon ball z so wouldn't you say
that half of the cast in dragon ball z
can beat goku
no he technically looks like he
literally fought goku and killed him
that it means that he beat goku wait
goku is fighting goku yeah so drac
welcome to dragon ball super buddy so
without having watched dragon ball super
i know they go to like multiple
universes
and i'm gonna guess that uh this comes
from
one of the multiple universes that's
right but the thing is right super
saiyan black goku goes to the other
universe yourself can beat yourself it's
not this is super saiyan black that's
goku right no it's super saiyan black
shoot he's
wait what's the line again don't shoot
he isn't black oh yeah that's it
he is i don't know if you you should get
a character that can beat goku he's
literally a character that kills goku is
that not a character that can beat goku
so would you say that majin buu is a
character that can beat goku yeah
because he literally kills goku yeah but
goku comes back and then beats margaret
have you maybe considered that goku
maybe isn't all that strong
[Music]
the [ __ ] joe
what are you saying you can't say that
the [ __ ] dies like six times i
don't think a guy who dies six times in
his own show is considered saw that
strong dying so much and coming back how
does that ask toriyama dude okay okay
but can he beat goku now in the latest
episode of dragon ball super right
because otherwise otherwise half of the
characters in anime can be like child
goku when he was a kid you know just
because someone can beat him you are at
some point
should have been more specific with the
challenges in that case i don't know
come on what do you think about this
connor what do you think about this i
literally searched up characters that
have killed goku and he was the first
one that came up and i literally saw
perfectly the exact same form as well of
when he this is the hand that took
goku's life right here i think it's [ __ ]
but it's alright you can have the
[ __ ] point thank you all right thank
you i don't know
honestly my kindness dude if this wasn't
gonna pass i was about to [ __ ] quit
wait did was that the only thing you can
think of was there like no other there
were possibilities see the problem is
all the other characters that can all
the other characters in dragon ball that
have killed goku canonically just don't
exist honestly
it's all dragon ball super characters
right now i thought you were going to
pick like a jojo character like if if
you would pick like like who like um
like gold experience requiem or
something like that then i'd be like you
know what
you know what there's a dragon ball fan
out there that has an argument against
that rohan rohan
could be
no no see like i see that all of that is
see all of that is your own opinion
because you guys love jojo more than
dragon ball z this is this is canonical
facts
all right dragon ball
fans what what do you think you have the
final say we're gonna give him the point
now but uh you have the final say in the
comments section if you say no to this
then i think you should quit being a
dragon ball
bring bring bring on the bring back
monolith holy crap oh
my god
the structural integrity of this seems
questionable that looks amazing that is
actually one of the coolest things i've
ever seen [ __ ] i regret nothing oh my
god
i hate that it's good
look at that look at that that's like a
statue you'd win at an award
dude that's that's
you know what you know what i'ma say it
[ __ ] amelia
[ __ ] emilia [ __ ] the hands
[ __ ] the hentai figure
every penny where do we put this
i i don't know guys right away well
where do we put this i'm just saying
though it's like perfect diamond for
that little area behind the toilet
come on come on guys come on this
doesn't deserve to go in the toilet
oh my goodness this would be great to
look at while it's pissing this looks
even better in like in person than it
did in the pictures it's pretty good
get this out of here get this out of my
sight
we'll keep you in there
it's literally blocking my camera guys
it's all right it's blocking
let me look at it for just putting up
it's taking up like a quarter of
it's not even a figure at this point
it's a statue it's a statue
and the final figure from lashing man
well what was your challenge i'll tell
you what my challenge i'll tell you the
story go on it was to buy a non-anime
figure okay and i'm surprisingly very
difficult because i thought okay well if
i bought something like overwatch you'd
be like oh no
there's overwatch animations it doesn't
count yeah you know there's all this
nonsense and [ __ ] that you guys would be
[ __ ] mean about and then i found the
terminator figure and i thought oh
that'd be great turns out there's a
terminator terminated yeah
coming out or something
everything i found had an anime found
some star wars figures i was like oh
fantastic no there's a star wars
literally just cam
came out right it's like they're trying
to make this [ __ ] difficult for me
they're trying to attack me so close
your eyes okay
truly
the best figure i've ever purchased that
doesn't have an enemy doesn't that have
an anime no the jacket
check this [ __ ] out
what
[Laughter]
is that 100
[ __ ] is that fantastic beast yeah that
is fantastic oh my god i didn't even
know they sold this why do they sell
gellard grindelwald who is that that
doesn't sound like a real character it's
um
that's meant to be johnny depp oh [ __ ]
sake 200 200 the only thing i could find
and after i purchased it in the video i
found a figure that would have met the
criteria for like one dollar or was it i
couldn't remember what it was it was
something i was pissed off i buried it
in my mind what is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
this movie sucked
i haven't even seen fantastic i haven't
even seen it yeah yeah [ __ ] it's me why
is this like [ __ ] oh it looks [ __ ]
oh i guess why does it smell so bad yeah
i i guess connor you can keep that one
for yourself no no no no no
you should
of course you want grindelwald on the
set who wouldn't want grindelwald uh uh
kellet grindelwald
he looks like he's mid transformation
into edward scissors hands what so can
someone explain fantastic beasts to me
it's it's it's a spin-off of the harry
potter series right i'm pretty sure yeah
it's set in the same universe but it
doesn't mention hogwarts or any of its
characters
it's it's the time before oh sorry well
you know i haven't seen it i enjoyed the
first movie a lot no yeah i was excited
for the second movie did you like gerald
grindelwald or whatever that was fun
and the second movie was [ __ ] it was so
bad and i was really annoyed because i
really liked the first one yeah and i'm
pissed is he only in the second one
uh he appears like a little bit in the
first round but like like so what's the
plot of fantastic beasts oh [ __ ] off
it's complicated is it yeah
i've never known what has got to do with
harry potter this is the main bad guy
it's just in the same universe
that's it yeah yeah it's in the same
universe as it's written by jk yeah okay
okay i could see oh wow his joints move
oh you can make him you can make him
walk you can get on his knees
you know connor at least it's not a
funko pop yeah exactly you don't lose a
point
[Music]
i think johnny depp is buying that i
kept them in business
what i want to know is yeah who who is
buying fantastic beasts figures out of
here
i'm sure there are like harry potter
otaku's out there right yeah definitely
get this out of my life
yeah
don't say dumbledore but i did my i did
my challenge he is in the he is in the
movies yeah yeah and yeah that was uh
everything i bought in lashing bun yeah
same so how many did you buy three i
bought three i'm sure you spend gamers
three as well i spent five hundred and
seventy eight dollars in dashimbon wow
500.
8 000 no 589
i spent
572 dollars wow we were all really close
holy crap wait no this is a stop oh
never mind
am i bad
looks like i just spoiled myself last
time uh i spent
674 dollars